battlefield 2042's launch is so close
and yet there's something oddly missing
from the flurry of details trailers
previews and betas that have come out
recently the missing piece is hazard
zone the squad-based all-new game mode
to the battlefield franchise dice just
dropped his trailer showing the new
hazard zone and we've got all the
details spoiler alert it's a lot less
battle royale and a lot more division
style dark zone a quick note is that we
don't have a lot of footage of hazard
zone other than the official trailer so
most gameplay you'll see is from the all
out warfare beta do me a solid and hit
that like button and subscribe because
we have battlefield 2042 live streams
beta breakdowns gameplay and so much
more on the channel and you won't want
to miss a thing
battlefield hazard zone is not a battle
royale trust me dice really wants you to
know this they've been adamant about it
from the beginning what we have instead
is a smaller 24 or 32 player lobby with
multiple squads the objective is simple
strategize retrieve and extract you and
your squad are basically a group of
notepad specialists that are tasked with
securing valuable intel on each map
you're fighting other squads in time and
the terrain you have limited time to
secure the intel and make it to an
aircraft and you can do this repeatedly
with the risk increasing each time
multiple squads have the same objective
so you need to decide if it is worth
fighting or avoiding each other squat
fights are merely a byproduct of your
true goal of simply securing the downed
satellite's data i'm not entirely sure
but i think that there will be ai
enemies as well our preview briefing
mentioned that occupying forces are also
a threat this leads me to believe that
ai us or russian forces will be
defending certain satellites if the ai
is involved
that could be a problem judging from
just how goofy they were during the beta
but we'll have to wait and see what i
know about the occupying forces is that
they will acquire targets quickly and
they will focus on self-preservation
according to dice prolonged engagements
with them mean potential draining of
your resources not to mention all that
ruckus will potentially grab the
attention of a nearby squad hazard
zone's gameplay will consist of 24
players on last gen consoles while
series x and s ps5 and pc owners will be
in lobbies of up to 32 players tornadoes
will also drop down at random adding to
the tension if you go down you will
still have a shot at living to fight
another day by crawling to safety being
killed while you're down however will
place you on a spectator screen squad
mates can still get you back in the
fight using a reinforcement uplink found
scattered across the map or as a
tactical upgrade purchasable with dark
market credits more on the tactical
upgrades in the credits in just a bit
though finally hazard zone will be
playable on all of the launch maps
confirmed for all out warfare including
orbital manifest hourglass and more
there will only be two extraction zones
one early on and one at the end of the
match and both zones will be in
different locations this means that only
two squads will make it out alive or
potentially none at all a match will
most likely go like this before each
game your squad will be briefed with a
predetermined starting zone that will
kick off your match's first phase which
is strategize and equip based on the map
in your starting zone your squad will
decide which specialist to use what
weapons and equipment you'll need and
the overall game plan specialists will
be locked to one player so no army of
boris's or falx instead you'll have to
appropriately synergize and consider the
team composition working with each
specialist advantage or disadvantages
once you load in it is time to start the
retrieval and to search for data drives
an intel scanner is a unique hazard zone
gadget that will help you track down the
location of these data drives you will
definitely want to make sure one squad
member has that intel scanner because
that device will be essential to your
objective this leads you into the mid
game where new satellites will continue
to fall from the sky with more encrypted
data drives these satellites will be
even more valuable than those from the
early match being defended by the
occupying forces at this point you're
forced to make a decision do you take
the first extraction opportunity which
will open up halfway through the match
if you decide to play it safe and
extract now you will need to dip asap
and fight any other early squats to
board a waiting condor however if you're
the type to go for broke you'll be
rewarded for your confidence assuming
you're able to make it out alive these
squads will have to go for the second
and final extraction which is obviously
riskier since any remaining units will
be going for the same goal as you fight
over the final extraction zone with your
team if you fall behind and miss the
extraction you will lose everything you
acquired in the match however if a
single squad member manages to board the
condor the entire squad will be rewarded
so what exactly are the rewards they
come in the form of dark market credits
which you secure from extracting the
data these credits are only usable in
hazard zone and purchases will lead to
specific tactical upgrades there will be
two free upgrades like starting with
plus 20 armor or getting 50 additional
credits for kills and occupying forces
some examples of dark market tactical
upgrades are quick draw holster this
will let you switch weapons 15 faster
while another upgrade like faster
healing gives you a 20 boost to health
regeneration how many credits you get
depend on the data drives that you've
extracted each data drive has an
assigned value with later satellites
potentially having the higher value
drives dice refers to the dark market as
the first component of the metagame the
more tactical upgrades you have the
greater the chance of a successful round
the other parts of this meta involve
passive upgrades your loadout and your
extraction streak the extraction streak
is a level attached to each unique
specialist you play a successful round
increases your streak by one and failure
resets your streak back to zero but if
you're able to get a good streak going
you will be rewarded with discounts when
purchasing tactical upgrades or loadout
items so hazard zone is definitely not a
battle royale they were really right
about that it does though feel similar
to my experience playing the division's
dark zone except way more team based i'm
curious how balanced the dark market
might be or if new squads have a
fighting chance against souped-up teams
with the best upgrades only time will
tell and those of you with early access
will get your shot at the mode on
november 12th all other players will be
able to dive into hazard zone with
battlefield 2042's launch on november
19th let me know if you're excited about
hazard zone or still thinking about the
open beta that wrapped up we've got our
thoughts on the good the bad and the
ugly from what we've seen so far in
another video so stick to gamespot for
all things battlefield until next time
[Music]